vsauce kevin here with a really simple
question do you want this box of 1 000
candies and a mystery box which contains
either nothing or a million candies
or do you just want the mystery box
obviously you'll take both boxes because
you're getting the mystery box
either way might as well grab some
guaranteed candy too
right right wrong
maybe honestly i don't know
the thing is when it comes to taking
both boxes or
just the mystery box almost everyone
watching
this video will be absolutely sure that
they know the right answer
this is barely a problem let alone
one you'll never solve but here's what's
interesting
half of you will be certain that the
obvious answer is to take
both boxes and the other half of you
will be just
as sure the obvious answer is to take
only the mystery box how is that
possible
and why is there suddenly a grande genie
on my table
let's dissect this problem box a has
clear
value it's literally clear you can see
the contents are
1 000 candies the issue is mystery box b
the contents of box b are determined in
advance by our omniscient
all-knowing grande genie who predicts
what you'll choose with
near perfect accuracy if he predicts
you'll choose
both boxes he's put nothing in box b
if he predicts you'll only choose
mystery box b he's placed
a million candies you can't see
inside box b you can't touch it and
you don't know what the genie has
predicted before
you actually choose here's a question
who even came up with this did i just
make
this whole thing up no theoretical
physicist william newcomb devised this
problem
in 1960 and a decade later philosopher
robert nozick detailed this deep
philosophical fracture that makes two
equally obvious choices both right
and both wrong it's a
contradiction it's an antinomic
paradox here's why if you decide to take
both boxes the genie will likely have
predicted that
and put nothing in mystery box b maybe
genies don't like greedy players or
something
so if you choose both box a and box b
you'll wind up with only a few handfuls
of
candy if you decide to take
only mystery box b the genie will almost
certainly have predicted that too
and put a million candies inside maybe
as a reward
for your courageous choice either way
it's now obviously better for you to
just take
mystery box b because a million is a
much better prize than
1000 that's
one way to look at this problem and in a
2016
poll from the guardian 53.5
of over 30 000 survey respondents chose
to take
only mystery box b here's what the other
46 and a half percent thought the genie
has already
either put a million candies in the
mystery box
or not he could have set up the boxes a
day
a week a month ago the candy isn't going
to
suddenly appear or disappear based on
your decision if he's filled box b
with candy and you take both boxes
you'll get
a million plus 1 000 more from box a
which you can eat right away to
celebrate your amazingly clever
rationale
if he didn't fill box b he just
didn't you take both boxes and win your
small prize and this way you don't walk
away
empty-handed you can't really
lose worst case scenario the mystery box
is empty
but you still get 1 000 pieces of candy
which is 1 000 more than
zero so should you take
both boxes or just box b
what is actually going on here why
exactly has newcomb's paradox confounded
minds
for decades because it's pitting two
equally valid methods of reasoning
against
each other expected utility and
strategic
dominance let's recap the two options
with a little math
so we can get serious you may not have a
sweet tooth so let's switch prizes from
canvas
to money box a now contains one thousand
dollars
and box b either has one million dollars
or no dollars first we can see
our possible outcomes with a simple
payoff matrix basically we'll just
write out the four scenarios excuse me
grande if the genie predicts that you'll
take
box b and you choose box b
you'll get one million dollars if he
predicts you'll take box b
but you choose both boxes you'll win
one million one thousand dollars million
in box b
and the one thousand dollars in box a if
he predicts you're greedy and will take
both boxes but you choose just box b
then you get zero dollars and if the
genie's prediction is
both boxes and you choose both boxes
your prize is just the one thousand
dollars from
box a to put it another way these are
the outcomes when his prediction is
right
and these are the outcomes when his
prediction is wrong
okay we mapped out the potential
outcomes
now what how do we figure out
which choice is right
well we can actually calculate how
valuable a choice
is to you that's expected
utility it's like the math of making
a decision you simply take the result of
a choice
and multiply it by the probability of
the outcome
that'll give you a numerical value to
help inform
your decision so let's say the genie has
a 90
chance of predicting right we'd
calculate the expected utility of
choosing both boxes like this a 90
chance he's right means there's a 10
chance that he's wrong so
if we choose both boxes there's a 10
chance we win two money filled boxes
and a 90 chance that we're left with
just the 1 000
we multiply the 0.1 probability he's
wrong
by the payoff of one million one
thousand dollars from both boxes
and add that to the 90 chance he's right
which means
box b would be empty so that's 0.9
multiplied by just the one thousand
dollar box a
payoff this equals 101
000 if we assume that the genie is right
nine times out of ten
each time we choose both boxes we'd
theoretically gain
101 000 now let's find the expected
utility of choosing only box b
so that we can compare the two values
and determine
the best choice we get a million dollars
if we choose
box b when the genie predicts our choice
correctly if we stick with this 90
accuracy rate we multiply 0.9 by the 1
million dollar payoff
and then add 0.1 times the zero dollars
from the empty box when he's wrong
for a theoretical gain of 900
000 per game by using expected utility
as a reasoning framework the best choice
is to take only mystery box b because an
average payoff of nine hundred thousand
dollars is clearly better than one
hundred
and one thousand dollars obviously
that's the right way to solve this
problem
until it isn't the dominance principle
waltzes in and shouts
in which scenario can i win the most
because look the genie has put the money
in the mystery box or
he hasn't your choice comes down to
taking whatever is in
that box or taking whatever is in
that box plus box a the mystery box has
a value
of n and the genie has determined that
value
in advance n is either zero or
one million dollars so your choice is
between taking
n or taking n plus one thousand dollars
no matter what's inside box b your
decision is
do you just want something or do you
want
something plus 1 000 bucks you're gonna
get
something either way so you might as
well grab the extra cash
that's the right way to solve this
problem
until the expected utility people come
back
and prove that it isn't
newcomb's paradox presents a problem
with what mathematician martin gardner
described as
two flawless arguments that are
contradictory choosing just box b
makes perfect sense choosing both boxes
makes perfect sense so
are you still certain one is the obvious
answer
are we only left with our own personal
perception of the proper solution
i don't know pete hine a puzzle maker
mathematician and poet summarized
this confusion when he wrote a bit
beyond
perception's reach i sometimes believe i
see that life is two locked boxes each
containing the others key
my question is are you team both
or team just b
thank you for subscribing to me
sorry for rhyming and as always thanks
for watching
[Music]